welcome to this video playing moon moon
from Iceland 1830 rating this is not
happen too often at UCM rating
difference of almost 600 points but this
is the beauty of the five minute model
pairing also benefiting players that I
am that are somewhat lower rated in
comparison to their opponent it's very
difficult to get them to get higher
rated players to play in a challenge
type of system there's something very
often just decline and this way I also
get to play many very strong genes that
probably otherwise wouldn't even play
okay I'm I'm intending to go for deform
but he's really going to a great lengths
to prevent it um Jim can i play d4
anyway maybe I don't like Bishop g4 like
he's taking and then Bishop g4 I think
I'll invest move to prevent that and now
see how to how to play night III see
form it's also possible continuation
okay I play it in a manner restraint
fashion not rushing things Bishop g5
analysis this is very welcome a5 is a
questionable move because it gives away
b5 as a square and as a consequence also
see form should g5 v h6 is a good move
Bishop g5 would have been nice for me
but he prevented that
I could have played Bishop g5 instead of
a four but then he may be place see for
himself okay so on let's see yeah that's
interesting now I can go to see form
I'll just to be five I think p5 is good
Quincy seven it's a bit surprising now
he goes back to d8 you know how to play
deform I guess I'll the kuru Conde one
opposing the Queen this should be
promising for a white yeah let's see you
now more than one idea i can just take
deform i could also think about playing
e5 really opening up the game yeah but
this is just simple and good takes I
think I pray book takes yeah I have
substantial pressure against e6 ideas
lost quite some time with the Queen yeah
now I can take a night play knight c6
winning the Queen 196 better mmhmm yeah
but his guts he gets some material in
return I wonder if I just play rook see
one threatening night c7 isn't this just
very strong
Teague's I can also play night at five
yeah it's okay so many good moves you
don't know what to play night f5 is also
strong how to determine the maximum him
Roxy one maybe Bishop descended on night
c70 takes a form don't want that really
spending far too much time looking at
this nice position okay i play one one
of the one of the good moves maybe not
the best move but i did one at one point
I need to play one of them here I'm
threatening d6 so he needs to take and
now there's b7 hanging and if I they
probably this wasn't the best way to
play but it is good this is a good one
yeah I need to speed up can go to a six
and then 97 is impossible because of the
career because of the pin yeah the idea
is after knight c6 which I'm expecting
and go here intending but should be six
yeah five okay but I need to I need to
be quick I didn't really didn't really
exploit it to to the maximum I'm really
sure I'm an exchange up but it really
looked like there was more okay covering
I'm not sure why didn't we didn't take
with the rook
yeah okay I'm a bit down on time but
it's not like a big difference so I'm
still I'm pretty optimistic to to manage
the try and control yeah just take a
rope the fire for now this probably
enough it's a bit so I'm making the dark
square as a bit said it shouldn't be so
important Bishop c5 of course this is
the kind of stuff that can hurt you so
must be cautious with that what now just
improve a bit rope t7 also was possible
yeah I should play King age to move like
that to make sure I'm not caught on this
diagonal
I form I just I could just take the rook
he could have just taken the rook oh my
god Queen takes before oh this would
have been very costly against 600 points
lower than mine rating oh okay gambit
know his ruckus in trouble yeah this was
lucky Kim I'm glad to be able to
exchange Queens and now let's pin him on
the back rank that this Bishop isn't
isn't doing any harm yeah that's really
too much black resigned wow I really
overlooked that yet before protected
this tucked away Bishop on on on evade
Wow yeah I can play not it's it's any
move not just blundering stuff and I'm
really just winning by material count
young in the opening here important
points are that this a five move is
really strange because it gives me it
just doesn't really help like in any in
any way and it gives me the the light
squares on the queenside and yet it's
already rather tricky for black I guess
he won't manage to get a good game
anymore he has played Queen to be six
Queen to c7 and back to the eighth i
mean this does not help well all whites
moves on in some way useful move like h3
for example it's not a time loss because
Bishop g4 can be nigh diem
Tiant gets it gets really really ugly
for blacking yeah this isn't the best
one it's not a bad move but not the best
probably what I actually overlooked is
that after taking I can go here and this
is very really convincing I'm winning an
exchange and here's no compensation
whatsoever just went on ok this is also
very good of course yeah it's hard to
tell i mean if you analyze it afterwards
you can easily spot some some better
continuation but what keeps keeps step
substantial advantage anyway here who
takes i was expecting more but it
probably does not matter yeah of course
I'm lucky that I blood of the rook NT
didn't take it alright thanks for
watching